Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
they screened the first episode of The Flash
at Comic Con, Legally.
So this is going to be my non-spoilery review.
Since a lot of you probably won’t get to
see it until October 7th when it officially
premieres, I’m going to do no-spoilers first,
then for everyone that has already seen it,
I will have a spoiler section with a special
warning.
Hello any new people too, if you’re just
finding me I do weekly Flash and Arrow videos,
be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’ve got a special Flash and Arrow Comic
Con Giveaway and I’ll explain what’s going
on with those panels because I will be uploading
them.
Flash Review first.
I feel like because of what this show is,
the cast they picked and the creative team
behind it, the trailers they’ve posted tell
you everything up front.
So watching the actual episode doesn’t reveal
anything comic book readers or Arrow fans
didn’t already know.
It’s through and through all the best stuff
from Arrow, but done in the light of day with
more humor.
That’s because Barry Allen is much more
positive than Oliver Queen.
If you saw Grant Gustin on Arrow, his portrayal
of Barry is virtually unchanged.
They haven’t messed with the character or
anything.
It’s a direct continuation and because so
much time has passed, they deal with those
time gaps in very creative ways.
If you haven’t see Arrow before then all
I can say is that Grant Gustin has the perfect
kind of energy for The Flash.
He’s like this hyper-curious best friend
type that makes you feel like he’ll definitely
be Justice League material some day.
This show is all about his origin story.
So give him a few years to get the moves down
and he’ll be running laps around Superman
in no time.
Just to clarify, I’m not talking about Grant
Gustin being in Justice League, I’m talking
about the comic book version of the Flash
joining the Justice League.
He’s an A List member, top tier level powers.
When he’s able to draw enough energy from
the Speed Force he can run so fast he travels
forward and backward in time.
Time Travel powers combined with the ability
to outrun Superman automatically make you
an A-List superhero.
The Flash we meet in the first episode is
just starting to figure things out and put
his own Team Arrow together.
I guess we can call them Team Flash, all the
supporting characters are great.
Including Detective Pretty Boy played by Rick
Cosnett.
I feel like because his name is Edward Thawne,
everyone is going to go into the episode with
certain expectations and still come out surprised.
The definitely give a hat tip to the name
Thawne and the idea of running fast, but even
knowing everything I knew before hand.
I was still blown away by a few big left turns
in the plot.
Team Flash, what forms initially at least
as Barry’s support circle are already characters
you’ve met.
Tom Cavanagh’s Harrison Wells character
is the person who runs STAR LABS is kind of
like a parental-type figure.
Not quite, but on the show he’s too old
to be like a Diggle character.
He feels more like a Slade Wilson from Arrow
Season 1.
Only in that he’s a mentor.
They come together in this really interesting
way.
There are a lot of comic book easter eggs
and the show is thus far, the most faithful
comic book adaptation DC has done.
It’s more faithful to the Flash comics than
Arrow is to the comics, just to give you something
to compare it to.
The Villain they use to call Barry to Action
is someone you guys will really enjoy.
The way they integrate the Particle Accelerator
Explosion and all the superpowers totally
worked for me and visually it looked great.
The big concern with a show like this is the
expense of doing superpowers on screen every
week.
During the era of Smallville it would have
cost ten times as much to do what this first
episode does.
And it’s only going to get cheaper as seasons
progress.
Seriously, I have no doubt that we’ll see
a season 2, I don’t expect them to make
an announcement until after the first couple
of episodes have aired.
But this will be one of the strongest new
shows the CW has.
They’ve already announced several additional
comic book characters coming on the show including
Robbie Amell as Firestorm and now Plastique.
If you remember, Arrow took it easy on Comic
Book stuff when it first started.
Well the Flash is going full throttle.
And that includes Arrow crossovers.
Right now the mid season finale of both shows
will be a two hour crossover event.
Each shows will have a two parter.
The first part will comprise that two hour
crossover, the second parts will be dealt
with separately when the seasons come back.
That just gets me so pumped for both shows
this fall.
And yes, I will be doing weekly vids for both
shows.
I know a lot of you have been asking.
So now I’m going to talk about some of my
specific favorite moments which means spoilers,
so careful in case you don’t want to know
anything.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Amongst many many favorites, I think my biggest
moment of Joy was the Harrison Wells reveal
at the end.
Right off the bat I’ll say I’m thinking
the show is going to use him as a Flash, Grant
Gustin of course and Edward Thawne, detective
pretty boy.
Here’s the thing, if they’re taking a
lot of plot cues from Flash Rebirth think
about how Geoff Johns made the transition
from the Eobard Thawne Professor Zoom to the
next one, Hunter Zolomon.
I think Harrison Wells is either going to
be The Rival inhabiting the body of Max Mercury,
he has the ability to time travel via the
Speed Force which explains the newspaper from
the future or he’s Eobard Thawne, the true
Professor Zoom.
Regardless of which Reverse Flash he is, I
think Edward Thawne on the show is going to
become the Hunter Zolomon character.
They’ll just give him Hunter Zolomon’s
story.
The Gorilla Grodd easter egg was something
the producers had to fight to keep in.
Really, the network was going to take it out
but they said it had to stay in just to give
us that WTF awesome moment.
I don’t think they’ll use the Grodd character
anytime soon, but he could totally be here
in season 2.
Think of his story as like a Dawn of the Planet
of the Apes situation.
As for Team Flash, now that we know Robbie
Amell is playing Caitlin Snow’s supposedly
dead fiancee, Ronnie Raymond aka Firestorm.
I’m wondering if they’ll still drive her
to the darkside like her comic book persona,
Killer Frost.
Something big would have to happen between
her and Firestorm for her to turn on the team.
Robbie Amell’s character is debuting in
the fourth episode.
And yes, they are doing the Martin Stein thing.
He’s going to be a character on the show
that we’ll meet eventually.
No word on what the Firestorm costume will
look like, but expect it to be a slightly
modified from the comics like Grant Gustin’s
Flash costume.
They’ll probably dig some Star Labs tech
out to help him contain his Firestorm powers
whenever he activates them.
That final Future Newspaper everyone has been
freaking out over is what’s going to inform
the major arc of season 1.
Eventually Team Flash will learn what’s
going on with Harrison Wells, what he’s
trying to do.
Here’s a crackpot theory, in the newspaper
it says “Flash Dissappears”, what if he
dissapeared to the past and Harrison Wells
is really Barry Allen?
I don’t think that’s the case, mostly
because Harrison Wells had been shown working
at STAR Labs as a brilliant scientist for
a long period of time.
Barry Allen is not a brilliant scientist,
he’s clever, but he’s not an expert at
Theoretical Particle Physics.
Harrison Wells is someone else.
But I do think he’s trying to affect a future
outcome by changing the past.
All Flash stories become Time Travel stories
at a certain point.
But let me know what your favorite moment
was and here’s the details on what’s happening
at Comic Con and my giveaways.
The Flash isn’t doing a separate panel on
it’s own.
Saturday Night in Hall H Stephen Amell is
hosting a superpanel where all of the new
DC Shows are going to be featured.
That includes the cast of The Flash, Gotham,
Constantine and of course Arrow.
Arrow is also doing it’s own panel on Friday.
I’ll be recording both of those and posting
footage.
So be sure to subscribe to get all that stuff.
Because Marvel’s panel is on the same night
I’ll be uploading that first, but I should
have the Flash and Arrow stuff uploaded by
midnight Saturday.
I will be live tweeting so you can follow
me on social if you want.
Links for that in the description.
I’m also posting reviews for Constantine
and Gotham this weekend too for those asking.
My Flash And Arrow Giveaways are pretty simple.
I’m giving away Funko Pop Arrow and Flash
figures.
I’ll pick two random people from the comments
next week.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
I’m going to be posting a lot of comic con
videos this week.
I’ll be adding them all to a special Comic
Con Playlist on my channel.
You can click here to watch my Marvel Preview.
That also starts the playlist.
And you can click here to learn all about
Robbie Amell’s Firestorm character.
Thanks for watching everyone, see you tomorrow.
High Fives!